foreign
[Music]
is that me
look uh there must be some mistake I can
get you more credits I can bring you in
warm
or I can bring you in cold
the addition of the book of Boba Fett
joins the Mandalorian on our list of the
best Disney plus original series
alongside Marvel phenomenons One
Division and Loki the streamer boasts
eight 100 scoring original series and 61
fresh titles overall so for this guide
we have set out to list Disney Plus's
best shows to binge watch that the
streamers put out since its conception
in 2017.
[Music]
okay
my wife are the flying saucers my
husband and his indestructible head to
be included in our list of the best
Disney Plus shows titles must be fresh
which means 60 or higher on the Tomato
Meter with at least 10 reviews so throw
on those Mickey ears as we count down
the best shows on Disney Plus
[Music]
number 10 the Mighty Ducks game changers
after failing to make the cut to join
the now Powerhouse Mighty Ducks junior
hockey team 12 year old Evan's mother
encourages him to form a new team of
underdogs with the help from Gordon
Bombay the duck's original Coach
starring Lauren Graham Brady noon Emilio
Estevez and created by Stephen Brill
Josh Goldsmith and Kathy yuspa critics
say game changers doesn't quite flip the
puck but it has enough heart and good
humor to make the Mighty Ducks proud
here it is
[Music]
Nature's Ice Palace
where's Nature's Wi-Fi and Nature's
cocoa bar a frozen pond
no no no no no no no no no you're doing
it again because we've all seen the
movie where the kids skate out into the
frozen pond and then there's a crack and
a splash and then they're all dead look
you got a team that is falling apart is
the best place for them to work it out
and to just play the ice isn't going to
break you got to trust me this is where
I learned how to skate
pond hockey shinny pickup whatever you
call it it's the reason why so many kids
fall in love with the game when it's
played out here on the pond there are no
boards no zones and no one in the stands
out here is where you get the Tactical
Edge on your opponent
so we're going to develop your your
Sixth Sense Instinct yeah my instinct
tells me I'm more of an indoor person
that's why we're going to start small no
gear no skates
just feel the ice under your feet
doesn't make me nervous at all we're
totally not going to fall through the
ice
I think I saw a bear number nine Doogie
came Aloha MD
lahila Doogie came Aloha juggles a
budding medical career and life as a
teenager starring Peyton Elizabeth Lee
Jason Scott Lee Jeffrey Boyer Chapman
and created by Courtney Kang critics say
with a winning cast and great bedside
manner Doogie Kami Aloha MD pays homage
to its predecessor while successfully
carving its own Charming path
foreign
as a doctor you learn all there is to
know about the human body
how blood flows how muscles contract how
the ileocecal valve can fail and allow
colonic reflux to overwhelm the
sphincter
sorry I'm on my GI rotation and it is
fascinating
but what's harder to figure out
is how two people who seemingly have
nothing in common
can fall in love
[Music]
and you hear those words for the first
time
[Music]
it's the most amazing feeling in the
world
number eight Wanda Vision living
idealized Suburban lives super powered
beings wand and vision begin to suspect
that everything is not as it seems
starring Elizabeth Olsen Paul Bettany
Tiana Paris and Catherine Hahn critics
say part loving homage to TV History
part of kilter Mystery One Division is a
wonderfully weird and strikingly bold
step into the small screen for the MCU
and a perfect showcase for Elizabeth
Olsen and Paul Bettany
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
number seven Hawkeye Clint Barton and
Kate Bishop shoot a few arrows and try
to avoid becoming the target themselves
starring Jeremy Renner Haley Seinfeld
Vera Farmiga and created by Jonathan
igla and Rhys Thomas critics say Hawkeye
starts slowly but the street level
action is a refreshing change of pace
for the MCU and the chemistry between
its leads Sparkles even when the plot
lags
well I hope you enjoyed the bruschetta
because it looks like you already lost
him he's in the elevator well yeah what
out of 65 floors you think you're just
gonna magically guess which one he's on
12th floor
enjoy the party
no no Kate stay
ah
no
foreign
what was that I don't know
oh my God
did you plan that yes
no no
no
[Music]
come on that is so annoying
number six Loki
Loki the god of Mischief steps out of
his brother's Shadow to embark on an
adventure that takes place after the
events of Avengers end game starring Tom
Hiddleston Sophia dimartino Owen Wilson
and created by Michael Waldron critics
say a delightful diversion from the MCU
as we know it Loki successfully sees
Stars Tom Hiddleston leap from beloved
villain to endearing anti-hero With a
Little Help from Owen Wilson in a series
that's as off-kilter charming and
vaguely dangerous as a demigod himself
Boston you Let the Wolves through our
door we prefer snakes to wolves I've
eaten both they die just the same
apologies
I betrayed you and now I'm King
about that you call me serious come on
what did you expect it was not the
bargain I gave you our location in
exchange for shelter and supplies you
give me your army and I take the throne
ah yes not so good at bargain
how about this one
my Army my Throne about that
scrubs we had a deal
[Music]
why the hell is there an alligator in
here
[Music]
Number Five Star Wars the Clone Wars
the first weekly TV series from
lucasfilm animation Chronicles The
Adventures of Anakin Skywalker Yoda
Obi-Wan Kenobi and other popular
characters from the Star Wars Universe
during the violent Clone Wars as
dwindling numbers of Jedi Knights
struggle to restore peace starring Matt
Lanter Ashley Eckstein Tom Kane and
James Arnold Taylor critics say within
agreeably entertaining first season Star
Wars the Clone Wars opens a fun
kid-friendly chapter the franchise is
sprawling mythology I may not be
capturing zero but you are going to
prison you're not a to mention it the
separatists are paying a million credits
for Jedi
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
number four the Mandalorian
after the fall of the Galactic Empire a
lone gun fighter makes his way through
the outer reaches of the Lawless Galaxy
starring Pedro Pascal Carl Weathers
Giancarlo Esposito and created by Jean
Favreau critics say action-packed and
expertly crafted if at times a bit too
withholding the Mandalorian is a welcome
addition to the Star Wars universe that
benefits greatly from the cuteness of
its cargo
[Music]
all right
[Music]
[Music]
oh my God
[Music]
[Music]
it's bearing my life
well this should be interesting
number three what if reimagining
noteworthy events in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and creating a
Multiverse of infinite possibilities
starring Jeffrey Wright Chadwick Boseman
Samuel L Jackson and created by AC
Bradley critics say what if may not add
much to the larger MCU narrative but
surprising takes on beloved characters
and some of the best action sequences in
the entire franchise make for engaging
viewing listen Bud clean up this mess
and leave this planet what no I like it
here everyone likes me we're having a
great time until you showed up parties
over pal hmm maybe here's a thought uh
how about you just buzz off
I wasn't asking hot shot
you know there's a mid-guardian word for
women like you
party pooper
okay this one's for Fury
now for the rest of you
foreign
[Music]
Star Wars visions
seven Japanese animation Studios bring
their unique perspectives to the Star
Wars Universe through a series of short
films starring Joseph Gordon-Levitt
kamiko Glenn and Karen fukuhara critics
say gorgeously animated and wildly
Creative Visions is an Eclectic but
wholly enjoyable collection of the Star
Wars stories that breathe new life into
the Galaxy
foreign
so you're a Jedi
it's been a long time since I killed a
Jedi
your lightsaber blade is red
coward unfortunately
I am not a Jedi
Jedi
and before we reveal number one here are
some honorable mentions
the mysterious Benedict Society
four gifted orphans are recruited by an
eccentric benefactor to go on a secret
mission placed undercover at a boarding
school known as The Institute they must
foil a nefarious plot with global
ramifications starring Tony Hale Kristen
Shaw Mommy and boafo and Ryan Hurst and
developed by Matt man Freddy and Phil
Haye critics say the mysterious Benedict
Society has a slow wind-up but its
delightful Supporting Cast and Sparky
tone make for winning family
entertainment I think what I would do is
flip the first witch
then wait 10 minutes
then I'd turn it off and flip the second
switch
then I'd check upstairs
if the light is on
then it's the second switch
if the light is off
then I touch the bulb
if it's hot then the first switch is the
one and if it's cold
then it's the third switch
very nice rainy well reason
yes that's great love rainy but that's a
lot of work when it's obviously the
second switch hmm why do you say that
any competent Builder would place the
light switch one and a half inches out
from the King's dead of the door jamb
and that would be the second switch it's
the other two are clearly dummy switches
I think the focus is less in
construction and I highly doubt that a
school such as this would contract with
a less than competent Builder I think
you're missing the point is it the
second switch Miss Wetherill is it the
second switch
foreign
yes
Star Wars the bad batch
members of a unique Squad of clones find
their way in a changing galaxy in the
aftermath of the Clone War starring D
Bradley Baker Ming Na Wen Stephen
Stanton and created by Dave filoni
critics say the bad batch is beautifully
animated adventure maybe too lore heavy
for casual viewers but fans will enjoy
diving deeper into this dastardly cast
of characters
what the
who threw that
I did now apologize to my friends
I like this kid
what did you say to me back off
I suggest you keep moving
know your place lab scrubber
oops that's it oh yeah
ah not again
[Music]
Miss Marvel
Kamala is a superhero fan with an
imagination particularly when it comes
to Captain Marvel Kamala feels like she
doesn't fit in at school and sometimes
even at home that is until she gets
super powers like the heroes that she's
looked up to starring Aman villani armis
Knight Sagar Shack and created by bisha
K Ali critics say Miss Marvel is a
genuinely fresh addition to the MCU both
stylistically and substantively with
Aman villani ably powering proceedings
with her super-sized charisma
found you
not sure what's worse those glasses you
try on or that mask are you following me
I sensed the Noor
[Music]
to all my family can have superpowers
well how do you know I'm not Canadian
you're wearing a shirt that says New
Jersey what is this look no one likes
the outfit huh
[Music]
come on
[Music]
and finally number one Diary of a future
president
Elena canaro Reed will one day become
president of the United States but for
now she's navigating her first year in
the jungle that is Middle School as a
sixth grader in Miami Elena learns
valuable lessons that will lay the
foundation for her future success
alongside best friend Sasha brother
Bobby mother Gabby and her mother's new
boyfriend Sam Elena documents the
pivotal highs and lows of her journey
into her trusty diary starring Tess
Romero Charlie Bushnell Salinas Leyva
and Michael Weaver Nick Allen from Roger
ebert.com says it's all tackled with a
wit and sincerity that simply comes from
thoughtful writing a trait that is
apparent in each of the first five
episodes
hello Elena it is on Elena
this is embarrassing
one of us is going to have to change not
me I'm on the precipice of greatness wow
queen bee much hey people use that term
as a negative but no one in the hive
Works harder than Queen B oh I know
there's this riveting documentary heavy
as the honey Crown I found it
fascinating me too I thought it was a
Stern but fair portrayal of high
mentality
but this
I mean you got to tone this down why
Senator Morales said I was born to lead
sure if leading is throwing yourself a
one-woman parade what is your problem
I'm the voice in your head so really
what's your problem
okay I don't need your judgment time to
quote Eleanor Roosevelt as Eleanor
Roosevelt says
no one can make me feel inferior without
my consent so bye well my friends that
about does it for us be sure to stay
tuned to the Rotten Tomatoes channel for
more of the entertainment content you
love until next time I'm your host Naz
Perez and we'll see you back here for
more top tens on the Rotten Tomatoes
countdown
foreign
[Music]